today has been wild being here on the
set of ravens home no less on such an
exciting day 100 episodes 200 episodes
since this whole journey really even
began it's such a big deal
[Applause]
so it's a really special day on set cake
and balloons and you can just like feel
the energy oh it's pretty
good
okay
it looks moist
i have to tell you i can't even put into
words how magical it is for me to be
here today because you're your og
partner in crime annalisa she's back on
this episode as chelsea
curses for raising such beautiful
generous children
i am so good at mothering i'm too good
you are ray you're a hero thank you
how does it feel to be reunited it feels
great the eps of the show
had a wonderful idea to make the 100th
episode 100th celebration on camera as
well so we are celebrating off camera on
camera i can't even take full
responsibility for the comeback it's
everyone involved because they know how
important it is is it like riding a bike
you and raven in a scene together yes
it's like riding a bike and this time
coming back as a guest star without
training wheels you know what i mean
it's crazy you know what i wasn't sure
i wasn't sure how i'd feel you know a
little indifferent of course bittersweet
missing everyone but it's it's not been
any bit no no bitterness only sweetness
just sweet because i'm seeing so many
people that i haven't seen and you
realize it's all just creative and you
know the show everything moves along
with you i think we've done such a
splendid job of staying friends
remaining friends remaining respectful
and loving each other while also um
um
teaching each other a lot and helping
each other grow and bringing out the
best of each other
you gonna get that
no not right now
raven is not home
you've been there since the very
beginning and to watch your girls raven
and and to be reunited with analisa
today what does that feel like i feel
like you got old that's what it feels
like you're looking at them going you
got a little bit older i mean i look at
me and i go i got a lot over here yeah i
i got a lot older this week has been a
charm because there's certain things
that
analisa brings to the table that i
forget until i see her doing it live and
then you you just go oh yeah i forgot
you're that good and the fact you go you
were that good and you were 16 years old
and like
how is that possible oh my god liska is
the best in the whole wide world we love
annalisa so much and having her back
with us is such a joy and she's she's
always brought such life to our set we
break for lunch at 12 but 11 30 11 45
she'll go that's lunch one hour that's
lunch one hour
and uh we got that iconic moment back
this week so it's so great to have her
back the fantastic chemistry between her
and raven is just like a joy to watch
and as for scenes with her it's just
like any time you're with her it's just
like
it's like when you're with a great actor
like raven or annelise or all of these
cast members you just you naturally want
to do better and you naturally want to
improve yourself i was very excited when
i found out she was coming i was like
yes let's go i think it feels really
right to have annalise back in san
francisco um with ray and with
with booker again you know um but now
with us too it's it's it's just been
really really really fun to see and
she's so wonderful behind the scenes too
she's just the sweetest sweetest lady
ever and wickedly funny wickedly funny
yeah and so it was exciting when i first
auditioned for neil
he was slated to be kind of
booker's chelsea in a way and so
not to mimic or copy her but there was
definitely inspiration from that she is
hilarious
and um i have always been a big fan of
raven's home i've literally seen every
single episode before i came on not in
preparation just i love the show yeah
and so meeting her i was like i'm a big
fan huge fan and she was like i'm a big
fan too and so yeah it was incredible
listen anytime raven and chelsea are in
the same room together chaos and madness
ensues as a viewer we love it we're
obsessed with it can't get enough of it
what can you tell me you're back here
doing today i saw you wearing knee pads
we've got some knee pads on underneath
these adorable pants that can only mean
i just got knee surgery no i'm just
kidding on both knees at the same time
but there may be a
event involved
crawling through a vent maybe maybe did
we ever call flu event before
i don't know was there stinky cheese
involved um
i don't know uh we'll we'll you know
it's just so great to be back with
rondell too on set with rondell and
seeing these old sets seeing my old
couch that we used to be in um but we
get into hydrants man i wish i could
tell you more but but they're surprises
and to be honest i think they even re
wrote the script today so there might be
even more surprises for me that i don't
even know about
ready and
camera
action 100 episodes how do you feel
about this this huge monumental moment
it is amazing to be able to be a part of
a show that
has changed the course of my career i
have been a part of the raven baxter
franchise since i was 14 years old i'm
36 now and through this show i've been
able to
learn how to produce i've been able to
learn how to direct i've been able to
learn how to write a script and i'm able
to transform who i am as an artist
through this process and meet some
amazing people through it so it's been
amazing and i'm so happy where we are
right now it feels exactly what you
would imagine it feels nostalgic it
feels like coming home it is the 100th
episode of um raven's home and also the
200th episode of the franchise of that
so raven it's just incredibly full
circle i'm so proud of raven um it's
great to be back with all my old friends
the crew the cast and then of course
raven's directing and it's just so
amazing to see her blossom and to be a
part of something that's meant so much
to so many people not just myself there
are now parents
watching the show
that they watch when they're kids and
they're watching with their kids and
that just there's you know there's a
there's a lot i hadn't done the math
of 100 episodes of that so raven
plus
raven's home and then it just it's like
you don't see that that there's
very few shows they get to do that yeah
you're a very very small company with
some very esteemed shows that have
reached that incredible milestone yeah
yeah get that dirt off your shoulder
yeah i like that i like that yeah being
here today and witnessing you
directing and producing and starring all
at the same time i hope it goes on for
another 200 episodes
uh i'm curious though how do you think
you'll know when it is the right time to
maybe say goodbye to raven baxter i
think i'll know it's the right time to
say goodbye to raven baxter when the
checks run dry on this one
when disney says you know what
we're good
no i will i will always make sure that
we bring the best content we can no
matter how long it runs i personally
would love to transition my career as a
full-time director and producer i think
that you know
before
before this falls
before this falls honey all right
[Applause]
you